all right our next speaker is Yin xiaolu
from UC Berkeley
um currently a PhD student and he's been
doing some very interesting work in
establishing theoretical foundations for
near-term Quantum Advantage which I
believe he's going to tell us about
today so
here to talk about the complexity and
applications of random circuit sampling
so in 2019 Google claimed a Quantum
breakthrough that could change computing
this experiment is called random circuit
sampling which has three components
first we use current noisy intermediate
scale Quantum devices to sample form a
random Quantum circuit and second we use
a statistical test to evaluate how good
device is performing and third we claim
that the same performance cannot be
achieved classically
so these experiments represent a great
advance in physics experiments and from
the Cs perspective it represents a great
advance in exploring the high complexity
regime of quantum mechanics
so here's what the experiment is about
Google performed random circuit sampling
on 53 qubits with circuit depths up to
20 and the device has roughly one
percent noise per gate
so after collecting M samples from a
device we compute the statistical
measure called xcb which is basically a
linear function of the ideal probability
of the random circuit from these samples
so roughly speaking this statistical
measure is a score between zero and one
where zero means we are doing trivial
uniform sampling and one means perfect
sampling from the ID RCS and due to
noise experimentally
a score of 0.002 is achieved
so last year panchang Zhang developed a
Brute Force tensor Network algorithm to
achieve the same task using 500 gpus in
15 hours
however this is not really the end of
story because this algorithm runs in
exponential time and it's unlikely to be
practical with larger system size
so what is going on here is that there
is an exciting race between classical
and quantum so since 2019 there has been
larger RCS experiments up to 60 qubits
and in particular this algorithm already
struggles which this largest system size
so the central question here is will
there be news moving algorithms for
larger experiments
so today we will take a step back from
this exciting race and we will ask a
more fundamental question which is is
there convincing evidence from
complexity Theory showing that noisy RCS
experiments are inherently hard for
classical computers
so in part one we will report recent
progress to address discussion three
years after the experiments and in part
two we'll show a practical application
of RCs in Quantum benchmark
so there are multiple approaches to show
evidence of high complexity in RCS we
will only focus on the noisy regime
which is directly relevant to show that
even the tiny xcb achieved in recent
experiments is hard to achieve
classically
in 2019 Arizona gun formulated a
conjecture called X squats which says
that even a tiny correlation of order 1
over 2 to the N with the ideal RCS
distribution it's hard to achieve
classically
the reason that they had to formulate
the strong conjecture is because this
was necessary for them to support the
hardness of a tiny xcb experiments
so this has been a very reasonable
conjunctions in Spanish and therefore it
provides the complexity evidence that we
needed however last year recent work of
galatel cast out on these arguments
this sort of reopens the question is
there high complexity in noisy rcx
experiments
so this is the main result from my
recent paper called a polynomial time
classical algorithm for noisy random
circuit something
so what we show is the following we take
an RCS experiment which produces M
samples
and then we give a classical algorithm
that can also produce M samples which
takes poly M time this is could be
longer than experiment but not
externally longer
so these samples comes from a
distribution that is so close to the
experimental distribution such that no
statistical test can tell the difference
between the two
so here's the technical statement of the
algorithm basically it's a simple
correlated from this statement which
says that we can achieve small total
variation distance
foreign
which I choose the desired error to be
roughly 1 over n and then that guarantee
is in this image ability
okay
so what happens here is that the running
time of our algorithm is at most a
polynomial in the running time of the
experiments in order to begin
indistinguishable from the experiments
so an important remark here is that
currently the running time of this
algorithm is not practical it has run
him roughly amp to the power of one
origami where gamma is the noise per
case
so do we care about polynomial time
algorithms if it's not practical
the importance of polynomial time comes
from the question of understanding if
RCS is a asymptotic experimental
violation of the extended Church Twin
Cities which is a very fundamental
Concept in complexity Theory saying that
whether a model of computation can be
simulated classically in polynomial time
so the about result give a negative
answer to this question of course the
result has some conditions that I'm
happy to discuss if it comes up
okay so next we will have a slightly
more technical discussion about the role
of circuit depths
so as we see previously already in the
numerics due to noise the output
distribution of a noisy RCS experiment
is very close to uniform in fact it is
exponentially small in circuit depths
and therefore experimentally in order to
see anything non-trivial we need to
collect at least two to the B samples
this means that in general most
experiments and our algorithm have run
income exponentially in b
this means that using a large circuit
depth is Not Practical for both the
experiments and our algorithms however
there is a particularly interesting
regime
of log and depth that was known as The
Sweet Spot for scalable Quantum
Supremacy because in this regime
everything is fully scalable and both
experiments and our algorithm now have
polynomial income in the number of
qubits
so next we give a brief sketch of where
our result comes from
the intuition of the prior work of
Amazon gun is to consider this uh very
simple idea of find my pass integral so
basically if we look at this equation we
notice that the right hand side is the
sum of many many terms 2 to the ND many
terms and if we have a classical
algorithm we can just only sum over
polynomially such random paths and this
only gets exponentially small
correlation with the distribution
before they conjecture that no classical
algorithm can achieve better than one or
two to the end correlation
this team is very reasonable and in fact
our classical algorithm is actually
based on the same idea which shouldn't
work but somehow now it works
if we consider different bases
so what we do is to consider the passing
through in the polyphasis which we call
poly passenger
and the algorithm has two main ideas the
first main idea is that in the poly
basis the parts are highly non-uniform
unlike in the computational basis and
this is related to this remark saying
that due to noise the contribution of a
given holiday pass decays exponentially
with the number of non-identity powers
in this in the past and therefore we can
order the different tasks by importance
and only consider the most important
ones in our simulation algorithm and the
second idea is to design efficient
algorithms that actually can calculate
all of those important tasks to achieve
the desired error and the algorithm
actually uses this unitarity constraint
that was highlighted in the yellow
saying that
actually not all paths are possible only
those ones that obey the constraint of
mapping identity to only identities
is not trivial
okay so that's all for the algorithm so
here is a brief discussion
so we know that RCS is a exciting
experiment with multiple aspects first
it's a very powerful method for
benchmarking on devices which we will
see next and second
we know that the current exciting back
and forth with classical smoothly
strategies Inspire the continued
Improvement of quantum devices so this
is a very
um
good news for our field
here are some issues also with scaling
up RCS the first step is that
theoretically we give strong negative
evidence for RCS as a scalable
experimental violation of the extended
charge 2 instances
and there is a much more practical issue
of
it's much harder to perform verification
as the system gets bigger
overall this seems to be a very exciting
time to start developing new proposals
for new term quantum computational
Advantage with a better complexity
foundation and the particularly
interesting idea is the cryptographic
proof of autonomous protocols which has
a solid complexity Foundation is
verifiable the only issue is whether it
can be implemented on Newton quantum
computers and currently umash and
clusters are doing the resource
estimation for these protocols
so that's where we'll move to the
benchmarking any questions
yeah how about your next paper which I
really enjoy reading I guess I will
put it in a different way I would say
you know you keep noise constant as you
scale up then you're exponentially
approaching medium for distribution and
they see that or around the gates and
then you're algorithm you know works
because it just produces
but what I think is the most interesting
is that
the feature that you say in passive you
know
scales with one over the lines I think
this got fundamental on what you're
showing again is that in the low noise
regime they're actually you know as long
as the noise per cycle is
less than one then the algorithm is
pronounced but once you get into the iOS
regime then you start to produce
you know the
random secret summary I mean you're
converting to uniformity and then it
becomes
you know something new released
I guess my main thing I'm trying to say
is that when you say curly the time is
Not Practical I think that's fundamental
yeah yeah I agree so I have a two
remarks the first remark is that from
the theoretical perspective there is
still some chance that we can uh
significantly improve this running time
so that is truly uh a bit unclear but I
agree with uh that that please begin if
we do have very very small noise Brigade
then we do not expect a practice for
ourselves
you know qualitative properties right
what you need is noise spray guide Which
is less than
18 percent of qubits
yeah yeah you know which you also find
another way yeah and I think that's what
I don't think it's you know like
a practical feature I think the best two
momentary so
yeah I I yeah I agree with you thanks
okay so next we will discuss
applications of RCs in benchmarking so
we're benchmarking what we mean is to
design our wisdoms to learn about noise
in Quantum devices
so here is the central challenging
benchmarking which is how to deal with
crosstalk and correlated errors
so in particular here's a simple noise
model on the left hand side we have two
independent errors on two different
Gates each happens independently with
probability one percent on the right
hand side we have one error that happens
on both gates with probability one
percent
so
basically the goal is to distinguish
between the two cases
so using the standard technique called
randomized benchmarking which can
estimate the marginal error on
individual Gates it doesn't do the job
because it will just output one percent
on each scale in both cases
however a simple way to solve this
problem is to
find a way to estimate the total error
on this layer of gates and in this case
the left hand side has total average two
percent and the right hand side has
total area one percent
so next we will actually discuss an
algorithm for estimating the total error
in a layer of non-clifford gates
so interestingly this has been an open
challenge in the field of benchmarking
because the standard techniques that we
use for benchmarking like these type of
circuits only works for Clifford Gates
interestingly we show that basically
using srcs we can solve this problem and
interestingly it works for any two cubic
age regardless of Clippers and
non-clipper
so of course the motivation of this
algorithm comes from Google's
experiments
so in Google's experiments
xcb was also used as a proxy of the
Fidelity of their experiments which will
come back later
and if we look at the paper besides
Quantum Supremacy there is also this
very interesting claim that the noise in
their device was uncorrelated
so this is very interesting because we
have just seen that
distinguishing between correlated and
uncorrelated noise is a very challenging
task from the perspective benchmarking
so Google's claim must mean that there
is something interesting in the
experiment for benchmarking
okay so here's what this claim is about
in this figure we can see two types of
data
so the data points as the shown by the
circles and Crosses they represent the
xcb of the experiment which we can also
understood as the Fidelity and then
there is the black line which uh which
is called digital error model
which is a simple formula by simply
multiplying the individual gate
fidelities
so uh here we call this frb because
these individual errors come from the
standard randomized benchmarking
experiments
so the spirit behind this equation is
the independence so we know that for
independent events The Joint probability
is the probability of each individual
events so here is one way to think about
what's going on in this experiment
maybe the errors in the device is
uncorrelated in this case we can
curiously argue that the Fidelity should
equal to the probability of no error
which would be by Independence be the
product of the probability of nowhere on
each case so let's plot both things
the xcb is a proxy for Fidelity and then
we can also plot this digital error
model this simple product equation
if they agree with each other they
suggests that the hypothesis that the
noise in the device was uncorrelated is
correct which would be great news
because this is good news for four
tolerance
okay so there are two things happening
here first we have the observation that
the xcb agrees with the digital error
model in the experiments
and second we have the claim that this
coincidence in the experiment data
indicated that the noise in Google's
device is actually uncorrelated across
each two heat Gates
so basically a natural question is can
we understand this observation from a
theoretical perspective and more
generally could this observation be the
hint of a multi-cubit noise benchmarking
algorithm for non-clifford Gates
so we answer both questions
um positively we show that the xcb in
the experiment scales roughly as as e to
the minus t times C where T is the total
amount of noise in the arbitrarily
correlated noise model acting on each
layer of gates
and therefore we can use xcb to learn
the value of t
and as a corollary we show that if the
noise model was highly correlated then
XB would deviate from the digital error
model and this gives evidence that
supports Google's claim
so here's um some more details regarding
this result
let's consider arbitrary polynoise
Channel which is just the distribution
acting on
all of the poly operators and we want to
estimate the total error which is the
sum of all of the errors that are not
all identity
so here we assume the total error is
small meaning that this is not a
scalable argument we just want to
Benchmark
dozens of qubits
and what we show is theoretical evidence
for the exponential decay of average
Fidelity for random Quantum circuits
Fidelity just means the inner product
between the ideal Quantum State and the
mixed state generated by the experiments
so experimentally we actually estimate
Fidelity using xcb and this is because
Fidelity itself is hard to estimate it
takes exponentially many samples and
therefore
we use xcb as a sample efficient proxy
so now this algorithm is very clear we
just sample a bunch of random circuits
at different depths and then we estimate
xcb of each circuit and then we fit an
exponential decay function and obtain
the value of D where we use xcb as a
proxy for Fidelity in the second step
okay so now it's time to go back to the
original problem of understanding what's
going on in this observation that claims
uncorrelated noise
so for this we can go back to the
previous Point model
so in this point model basically there
is the anchor related and the correlated
noise model so let's think about what
happens with xdb and the digital error
model
so on the left hand side the total error
is two percent and therefore
xcb decays
as a rate of two percent
and of course both individual Gates have
every one percent so overall the digital
error model frb will also Decay with a
rate of two percent
on the right hand side the total error
is actually only one percent and
therefore xcb will only Decay with one
percent meanwhile because the digital
error model doesn't distinguish between
local and correlated noise it's still
the case as a rate of two percent
to see that we can heuristically
simulate a highly correlated noise model
and basically clearly see the difference
so in this case the frb will Decay much
much faster than xcbn fidelity
so a one sentence summary to this result
is that total error approximately equals
the sum of marginal errors implies low
correlated error and this is exactly
what's going on in this experiment
okay so here's the conclusion of the
talk
so first of all to achieve larger
speedups RCS and Quantum Supremacy
experiments motivate the development of
larger and better Quantum devices
and here the accumulated experimental
advances and the theoretical
understanding in complexity Theory
provides the foundation for the next
challenge problem for future devices
and second RCS provides a powerful
technique to Benchmark Quantum devices
such as estimating the total model noise
on a layer of non-clever to qubit Gates
and this allows us to provide formal
evidence to support Google's claim that
the the noise in their device was
unholated so that's all thank you
15 questions
foreign
complexity and computational complexity
of the estimator yeah
so as I said um basically what we use
vaccine because it's double efficient so
for each circuit if we want to estimate
with the action error it only requires
one over Epsilon Square samples and the
computation complexity of course is
exponential in general but this
algorithm is not meant for scalable
algorithm anyway so we just look at
small system size and that's made a
total
all right
foreign